hey guys now this is gonna be a very
interesting and quick informative video
in today's video i'm gonna show you five
very bad morning habits that will ruin
every man's day let's not waste any more
time let's get to it
[Music]
number one eating an unhealthy sugary
breakfast
like muffins donuts and even unhealthy
cereals it will immediately spike your
blood sugar levels you don't want that
because what goes up must come down
so not only is it bad for you your
insulin will spike stopping your body
from using your own fat for energy in
other words you won't lose weight if you
want to lose weight it's actually better
to do intermittent fasting
brushing your teeth after breakfast yeah
i know a lot of guys do it because they
think okay then they will smell good
right but it's actually better to brush
your teeth before you eat breakfast
because if you don't do it if you do it
the other way around you go and you
brush your teeth after breakfast the
enamel on your teeth will still be
sensitive especially if you eat acidic
food like dairy products certain fruits
and even coffee so if you brush your
teeth in that state you will damage your
enamel you don't want that that also
goes for those people who really brush
their teeth like ah like crazy no be
gentle be soft because you will damage
your enamel checking your phone when you
wake up
do you do that when you wake up you
can't even focus yet but you have to see
what's going on on social media or the
news
well to be honest i do that as well
sometimes and guys we gotta stop because
the world out there it's already too
busy especially if you feel that you
need to go to bed with your phone and
then the first thing your phone is
already there so you pick it up and you
go through your phone
already no if you do that if you read
your emails or read the news check your
social media you are immediately back
into that busy busy mode the rat race
some people even go into panic mode and
that all happens before your day has
even begun don't force your brain to
wake up with all these things all these
things that just craves your attention
just wake up with a more positive note
force yourself to do it too many people
out there go through unnecessary stress
and this is one of those reasons so
force yourself just to wake up with a
positive note switch off from the world
your phone can wait
not setting your mind on the right track
think about it do you just go with the
flow of the day or do you purposefully
set your mind on the right track by
setting intentions the best thing you
can do is to start the day with the
right frame of mind i usually start with
prayer and then i set my goals
this immediately helps me to see the
bigger picture of what i have to do in
the day and how the world works and it
gives me a lot of joy
and blue monday is not a blue monday for
me anymore a weekend friday is not a
weekend friday every day for me is the
same a day that i can have full joy and
you have to choose how you want to start
your day
sleeping too
late
is this you
well this depends on whether you work at
daytime or night time right but if you
sleep late just because you're lazy
that's a bad habit
you know i really don't
like it when lazy people just want
things for free you know those lazy guys
who say things like why is my life like
this it is unfair why people like ellen
musk is so rich have you ever even
thought this through
it's not unfair
he works hard for what he has he's even
developed a game when he was 12 years
old everything he sews he reaps there's
a lot of people who work extremely hard
for their success so why don't you go
and work hard for your success why don't
you go and invent stuff howard scolds
chairman and ceo of starbucks with a net
worth of 4.3 billion grew up extremely
poor there are a lot of successful
people today who worked really hard who
grew up poor
so that's why i'm also annoyed when
people make all these unnecessary
excuses especially when it comes to
white privilege because i was poor and i
work for what i have there are other
good examples as well ralph lauren
another white man who grew up poor not
being able to buy even clothes now he
has a net worth of 6.4 billion dollars
now let's stop looking at color that's
the biggest problem with this world
people always looking at color no you
are unique you're your own person and
you have the responsibility to take care
of your own life work hard for what you
want to achieve steel tycoon lakshmi
metal who came from india also grew up
in a poor family but through hard work
his net worth is now 17.8 billion and
man if you have not watched the pursuit
of happiness
man what a good movie you have to go and
watch it because it's based on a true
story it tells the story of the
successful businessman chris gardner who
worked extremely hard to achieve success
he went from being a struggling homeless
single father to building a successful
company and selling it in a
multi-million dollar deal you know i
wanted to show you these examples of
these men who work hard for what they
have for what they achieved in life
because in the day nature we live in i
just see more and more lazy people this
mindset of i just want quick fixes and i
don't really want to work hard for what
i have
and then the crime is rising because
people want to steal things and rather
rather just to work hard for it like a
man stop being lazy
stop your excuses and work hard for what
you want to achieve because then you
will pluck the fruits and it will be
worth you a lot more than just getting
things for free you will appreciate it
so stop hitting that snooze button stand
up stop being lazy and work hard for
your goals and you will reap what you
saw
now if you want to be more successful in
life there are daily bad habits that you
will need to stop not just morning
habits daily habits check out this video
here and he will help you before you go
always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys